naal border patrol council is backing
this border bill in a statement to Fox
Brandon Jud the president of the border
patrol union says the Border act will
codify its into law authorities that
border patrol agents never had in the
past this will allow us to remove single
adults expeditiously and without a
lengthy judicial review while not
perfect the Border Act of 2024 is a step
in the right direction and is far better
than the status quo Brandon Jud in focus
now I can only imagine that you've heard
from a few people who may not agree with
you so I I want to give you the chance
to tell me in short words what you like
about this bill and then let's go back
and forth a little bit with some of the
weaknesses so there are plenty of
weaknesses in here but there's there's
also a lot of strengths and and when you
look right now what we're currently
dealing with um this is a slow month and
we're dealing with 6700 apprehensions on
a daily basis what this would do is it
would cap it to where we couldn't take
anything more more than 5,000 now this
does not say that we're going to release
5,000 people into the United States in
fact it's it's the exact opposite it
says that we will hold single adults in
custody um they will not be subject to
release and so that is a huge deterent
that will deter an awful lot of people
from crossing our borders illegally we
know that the main magnet that that
people cross our borders is because
they're going to be releasing released
into the United States once you stop
that magnet you will you will stop an
awful lot of people from coming so
although it's not perfect it is a step
in the right direction and I would
rather have the step in the right
direction than nothing and consign me to
what the status quo is all right a
couple of questions for you um first of
all the 5,000 is an average 7 Day up to
8,500 would have to come across the
border which is more than what we're
seeing right now per day in a slow month
so we're actually going to see 2,000
more people coming across potentially as
long as the 7day average stays around
5,000 my question for you is do you know
even how they got to those numbers I I
don't know how they got to those num let
me tell you so the new Asylum system
would allow for 3,500 screening
interviews per day so what they're
hoping is they don't want to get too far
above that because they've got to keep
close to that number it would take
relatively two to three years to get
that new system in place so we might
have to live with what we've got for a
while I just put that out there um and
and I do want to point this out for all
of your men and women who need more help
the help will come in the form of these
Asylum interviews but you still are
tasked with the illegals coming across
the border do you know what in this bill
deals with them yeah so again when you
look at what we currently have to do
this bill allows border border patrol
processing coordinators to do the
paperwork we don't have to do that we're
we're able to deploy our resources to
the field under this bill we're no
longer administrative assistance under
this bill so again there's a lot of good
when we talk about 8,500 people all we
have to do is go back to December and I
will push back on that because in
December we were taking 12,000 people
into custody on a daily basis our 7-Day
average through the month of December
has been well above 5,000 and that is a
slow that is a slow month so this bill
puts a cap on on what can come across a
cap is much better than allowing
anything to come across because those
numbers could Skyrocket well above
12,000 so a cap is better than
absolutely nothing just wondering how
you will enforce the cap because if you
could shut down the border for any
period now that would have been part of
the conversation and just so you know
inside those conversations because
people are beginning to talk as they
come out of those chambers now just so
you know that was not that was an
absolute noo for Democrats they wouldn't
even discuss can we just get a catchup
that's what missing to me in all of this
so one just quick last one about people
sneaking across the border the new way
would have everybody get apprehended by
border patrol held in detention screened
at a much higher standard for Asylum and
then deported back home and I'm asking
this they've come across the border
sneak is the word in the documents I I
just they're criminals so you're you're
going to spend all of the resources our
taxpayer dollars still rather than just
deporting them back after after they've
broken the law they're going to be
according to the plan plenty of places
legally still where they can go across
the border I'm trying to get an idea of
how this immediately helps you because
three years from now is a really long
time Brandon yeah it is but what this
does is three months from now is a long
time by the way haris it is Harris but
what this does is it ties any future
president's hands so if we have another
president like Joe Biden this will
ensure that he doesn't do what he's
currently doing that is better than the
status quo again I'm going to look at
this is this bill better than the status
quo and it absolutely is nobody can
argue that nobody can argue that it's
not better than what we currently have
and so if it's better than what we
currently have why wouldn't I support it
obviously I'm going to do that because
it gives us border security measures
that we don't have that we've never had
and we need those border security
measures to counteract a president like
Joe Biden so what does it do for a
president like a trump or a republican
to get into office I mean doesn't their
hands at all perhaps if that were the
case you would get these numbers to be
even lower so Harris it doesn't take
away any executive Authority so if
president Trump well if that's the case
why can't we just use that now why can't
we use the the laws that are on the now
but he won't so why not tie his hands
with law that's what laws why do you
think he'd follow the laws coming that
you want to see changed if he won't even
follow the laws that are on the books
right now if he won't enforce what he's
got in the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court in 2023 said that he has the
authority to release people so we can
argue that he shouldn't release people
but our the Border down right now Harris
absolutely but this law ties his hands
this law doesn't allow the Supreme Court
to come in and say that he can release
people this law says that if you're
single adults you will be held in
custody it ties his hands and it will
tie any future president's hands so of
course I will support that it does not
limmit it's forat see the issue very
differently I don't know if we have time
to run this so I'll just read a little
bit of it Arizona border County official
Jonathan limes with this message to
Congress on the Senate Bill do not vote
Yes on this bill it's a starting point
sit down with the freedom caucus sit
down with all interested parties and
establish what needs to be done as a
baseline which is shutting the Border
down right now Brandon you and I have
known each other a long time you know
how much I support the border of Patrol
whatever Goes Forth has to to be much
better
immediately Harris we're not going to
get much better immediately so I'm going
to take those incremental steps if this
were going to tie Donald Trump's hands I
would be opposed to it immediately it
doesn't it doesn't TR tie any good
administration's hands so why you it I I
I have no idea I haven't spoken with him
about it if he if he has specific issues
let him air those issues I will give the
positive points in this bill there are
negative points but if we don't even let
this bill come to light if this bill
doesn't even go to the flo we don't even
get amendments and that's what
everybody's talking about everybody's
talking about killing it before you're
able to even offer amendments that's
wrong let's have the discussion look at
the bad points keep the good points but
look at the bad points and give
amendments to it what I like about what
you're saying is everybody needs to read
it and I have it's 370 Pages it's worth
it because the areas where it falls
short in dealing with oh we didn't even
get into Goda ways I mean this is a
conversation that would take you and I
who know each other well hours to get
through after reading that document I
appreciate your time and debating some
of the the uh the weak spots with me and
the president is set shortly to talk on
this we'll watch it together hopefully
thank you Brandon hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaye mckenny on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
sets your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights